I mean I'm not blowing smoke up your ass
you look [__] fantastic well thank
you and you know you've never made a
secret about you know you'll do PL
you'll take a nip and a tuck here and
there so many people screw that up if I
was going to do something to myself I
would go to your doctors do you know
what I mean do people call you all the
time and say Dolly how do you do it oh
yeah and I always say just find the best
doctors I even some of my celebrity
friends I give them the names of my of
the doctors that I've I've used but you
just got to be very careful not to
overdo it cuz you never know anytime you
go under the knife you could come out
looking not good just like when Kenny
had you know when Kenny Rogers
especially harder for men because you
can't wear the makeup and all the
different eyelashes and stuff but I mean
even and that was one of the best
doctors you just never know how you're
going to heal you never know what's
going to go so you absolutely need to
find the best doctors the most talked
about doctors are the ones highly
recommended if you're going to do
anything about your face you can cover
up stuff if somebody screws up things on
your body but boy if you live with your
face out there you got to be careful so
I try to do just little bits at a time I
don't do like you know really big stuff
and then I I do a lot of I do fillers
Botox and juvaderm or whatever you know
just the fillers and just only when I
have to you know do something and even
then I try to be be careful I've gone to
several doctors they tell me there's no
fixing my face they can't do it it's
you're beautiful as you are nobody wants
to change you but you know what Dolly
you're right about Kenny Rogers there
was a good-look man very he should have
left it alone he should have left it
alone but you know what he probably just
you know like how we all get that
sagging Dragon bagging thing you know
like if you're under your eyes you know
you think well I got to get these bags
out and somebody convinces you I know
the best eye doctor but you don't know
how you're going to heal and that's
what's so hard about it it can can it
changes your Expressions even if the
surgery itself is good it changes your
personality it can did you ever talk to
Kenny about it did you ever cuz you were
close yeah I was very close to Kenny and
I you know course I made him feel better
about it in fact one of the last times
we was together I we were like brother
and sister we just said whatever and I
told him I said Kenny I'm glad I got I
got to live long enough to see you grow
into your facelift you know so he
thought that was a funny thing but he
did you know as he got older you know
his skin you know started to loosen and
and he looked more you more natural but
it's always a risk and I'm always every
time I go in for anything I think oh
Lord please you know let this all work
ring the dice
yeah